quisiéramos empezar preguntándole qué
implicaciones puede tener que el papá
haya reconocido la participación de la
iglesia católica en un genocidio
cultural para otros pueblos indígenas
del continente americano
buenas tardes rosa mira la verdad que
este papá con este viaje este viaje de
penitencia como lo llamo fueron tres las
oraciones que para mí quedan ahí en él
van a quedar
retornando en el tiempo a la luz de la
historia primero hay una dijo que se
generó una mentalidad colonialista es lo
primero que dijo de acuerdo lo segundo
dijo hay una indiferencia de muchos
católicos ante este genocidio como él lo
llama y lo último que yo encuentro que
es es muy importante porque ningún papá
lo había dicho él dijo que había una
destrucción cultural
cuando uno plantea que hay una
destrucción cultural uno está diciendo
que hay una destrucción en la forma de
pensar en la forma de sentir en la forma
actuar de un grupo determinado de
personas y este grupo determinado
personas son estos pueblos originarios
yo me atrevería a plantear que el papá
francisco esto también podría extrapolar
lo a toda américa con la llegada de los
españoles y también con el proceso
evangelización así también como lo dijo
en su momento cuando lo segundo cuando
también pidió perdón por el genocidio
ahora bien el papá al subirse al avión
como ustedes muy bien lo decían plantea
esta opción de poder dejar su
pontificado él dice que no va a suceder
nada si él no se va a mirar yo estoy
convencido que el papá lo que está
haciendo
marcando la pauta venir le estaba
diciendo los cardenales prepárense
probablemente yo me voy
tiene que venir otra persona que tenga
las capacidades y las competencias que
yo he tenido hasta ahora creo yo
sinceramente que este papá le ha tocado
muy difícil el cuando aparece por
primera vez frente cuando es elegido
papá él dice recen por mí claro que
había que rezar por él estamos frente a
un hombre que ha se ha tenido que hacer
cargo de tanto tema tanto tema de abusos
como también de cambios en la estructura
interna del propio vaticano y
precisamente señor sánchez en relación a
esta posibilidad de retirarse lo hemos
visto muy disminuido ya en este viaje en
silla de ruedas la pregunta es todavía
le quedan cosas por hacer y por eso no
se retira ya de inmediato o podría tener
una cierta incertidumbre sobre quién
vaya a tomar el relevo al frente de la
iglesia católica
yo estoy convencido que el papá está muy
enfermo el papá tuvo una operación al
colon donde él mismo plantea que no
puede ser operado por un tema con la
anestesia pero al margen de eso el papá
ya no se puede parar tiene un problema
en la rodilla pero tiene otras otras
dolencias de acuerdo por lo que dicen
los médicos por tanto él se da cuenta
que esta iglesia católica como iniesta
necesita gente que esté con sus
competencias al cien por ciento
sinceramente yo creo que insisto este es
un llamado los cardenales prepárense
empecemos a buscar a la mejor persona
porque así como está la iglesia católica
si efectivamente no somos capaces de
poder salir adelante y enfrentar los
problemas como lo está haciendo este
papá pueden venir tiempos mucho más
difíciles de los que hayan venido eso lo
que está diciendo el papá con estos
anuncios